[music] we
put loneliness on what we will start a good
day of course we have seen in the last
how many days in the most important thing for ourselves we
have identified what the most pressing questions can be,
in principle, it’s not even
more or less clear what people
care about, but when a direct line is being prepared
in that  including in order to
fill the state budget or not
to do the first in order to achieve the
maximum result for our people
for our citizens for the development of the economy,
we organized work on the so
-called national projects, the
ultimate goal of all these activities
is to put the
economy on a new  rails to make it
high-tech to increase
productivity and on this basis
to raise the standard of living of our citizens to
ensure the security of our
state for a long historical
perspective, I will be these 50 rubles and
which I read on the screen and
now the attack on the hill where did it come from
and what is the meaning of the meaning only  in one
curbing the development of China, which has become a
global competitor to another global
power, the United States, the same thing is
happening with regard to Russia and will
continue to happen, therefore, if we want
to take such a
worthy place under the sun, we must
simply become stronger, including, and
above all, the economic sphere.  up to
20 percent, I repeat this, including
in order for it to act
according to expert data as a result of all these
restrictions of restrictions, Russia over the
years, starting from 14, somewhere
lost about 50 billion to the
European Union
lost 240 billion dollars, which is
exactly what we had to do in the first place
and  we did it to turn on the brains
about that, in my opinion, no, because the
threat to the country, to the nation, to our
people is very great and therefore if a
person is stored illegally on
transported, it means that it distributes
even small small
doses of small doses, you need to be responsible for this
and no liberalization
here  can't be  no, the situation has developed for you,
well, not frankly, it’s not the best,
nothing is being done, the blockade is only being
intensified, nothing is happening,
so steps towards this are the simplest,
political will from the
Ukrainian leadership is needed,
it’s not just about certain numbers,
but about how people feel
only our colleagues will be ready,
please, we will also answer this one
in the same way, especially since we
have something to talk about and in the field of international
security of destruction, I mean that the
START treaty will end
if you are 3 in the near future, yes, and from the point of
view of but a wife of normal
interstate  relations in all
areas, including saving money, we
should pay attention to this
because we do not need to inflate these bubbles in the economy,
even if the president wants to take
some steps towards wants to talk about something,
there are a lot of
restrictions associated with the activities of
other powerful  institutions,
especially since now the
current head of the  and the state will
look back at the demands on the demands of the
election campaign in which it has already
entered for each industry for each
region separately, so I and not three
others think that everything will not be so simple
and in our relations I mean that
part of the American establishment is not
speculating on Russian-  American
relations are trying to
catch it for themselves there in this troubled water, I
’ll come up with all sorts of things, as the children said, the freaks
started from 18 to 20 percent, I repeat this
, including so that the
University Times heard about this article and saw
the president’s reaction that they are not a
traitor and  but I don’t understand how we
should interpret this, it means they gave out the
existing real information, or
they nevertheless carried out some kind of reset,
but in any case, we must somehow react to this, we
must understand what
is at stake in the year the broadcast came
video  - the question is, I give the floor to our
near the center, you are sitting so they say that they do not
exclude and
I want to use armed force immediately with  to say this would be a
disaster for the region, at least
because because it would lead to a
surge in violence and there may be an increase, by the
way, and the number of refugees from the
region, the minimum wage of the
regional wear is applied